we've already done a lot of work to
introduce this idea okay so a lot of you
could probably guess what's going to
happen next right there is one and only
one client double equation kind of
function okay that fits this description
there's only one kind of function such
that when you differentiate it right now
we're talking to the actual calculus and
when you differentiate you get back a
version of itself just off by a constant
there's only one function like that and
it is well the aptly named exponential
function right it's where disturber
cultural okay we define this stuff by
the way we got it is by thinking about
something that's great occurs in
relation to its size okay so sorry the
exponential equation P equals now I'm
going to describe this in a second but
let me finish off the set is the
exponential equation such right is a
solution to
okay and by the way it's important you
phrase it this way okay especially it's
not the solution because there are
others are there what kinds of other
solutions might we introduced because
we're starting with the derivative right
I want the primitive we know there's a
whole family of previews that would all
fit right you could add a constant onto
here I'm gonna let you ever think about
why at the beginning at least we're not
going to talk about that constant
because adding that going on he make
thing he makes things to behave quite
differently okay we will get to him
because you guys are extension students
just out of curiosity to the students do
not this is the limit of exponential
growth or decay that they address but
this is a solution okay so let me give
you an example okay how does this thing
work I give you some rubbish um I
Charles I'll say us a question to you I
wouldn't put your pens down and then
we'll write down all the numbers
together so here's the situation a
town's population we're talking our
population will say this ring telus
population one day 5,000 people 5,000
people okay ten years later it's seven
thousand years later 7,000 okay now if
we assume that the population grows at a
rate that's proportional to its size
which is a reasonable assumption to make
okay it's kind of weird to think just
you know it trickles in at a cost of red
what would that be 200 people per year
or something like that that's not the
way populations tend to grow okay so if
the population is growing in this way
what will the population be five years
later okay now there was the idea let me
get down all those important details
again where do we start how many people
do a video with 5,000 people okay I've
did how long 10 years what was the
population 7,000
okay we shared that what was joining
these two okay was this idea this
proportionality growth time okay so now
that question is what happens after
another five years okay so what we're
doing here is we're modeling okay we've
got a situation and we're fitting
equations to the situation to see if we
can predict something that's what one
knows okay so being we've got this okay
part a of a question like this would
usually be to do this okay how do we do
it I know it seems a bit trivial but you
have to start this way you would say
follow let p know in a second you'll
work out what these letters are okay
we've already introduced as this closet
that tells us how fast things are happy
okay in a minute you can tell me what
capital a is ok but first we want to
show that it fits the information that
I've been given that it does grow it
this way proportional to its size okay
how did you do that how would you show
that this satisfies this okay I want to
differentiate in the left-hand side and
then have a look to the right hand side
I should be able to show that they come
to the same thing okay so i'll say and
therefore dp/dt okay so differentiate
what happens to it its trade rules it at
the cage comes out the front there you
go left hand side okay right hand side
is okay p okay well we're just to find
it like this
yeah really that was it yes that was you
don't take any shortcuts ok so you p
oops sorry this satisfies
okay so I've got my starting point now
what I'm going to use for my model does
fit what's required of me in the
question okay great that's what you're
under Part B which is working with this
okay how am I going to move from this
which is all abstract there's nothing to
do with a particular situation and deal
with the information they've given me
okay think of these all this points in
time think of the balls points in time
okay so this is my starting point right
let's call that time zero because that's
what we go when T equals zero okay the
population is 5000 okay so i'm going to
use this equation which i've introduced
and fit this information it okay let's
do it 5000 equals AE k times 0 ok so
what it's me a is equal to five thousand
ok now it's for this reason right hey
why do we call a and not like B or C or
D does second doesn't either Katie just
rolls off the time we call acres a is a
first letter in the alphabet it's your
starting point okay alternatively you
will see it just as frequently said
don't necessarily a decay to but p
equals p naught ok team why do you think
they give that because it's a population
at time 0 okay you will see both of
these equally frequently okay good now
I've got a value for a how do i need to
progress i'm trying to get towards
something over here right or what I do
next
well there's another constant in there
which I do not know right namely k by
the way because that k is there and it
defines this equation it's also called
the constant of proportionality there's
a lot of arm is on a words and phrases
in this sub topic and that shouldn't
surprise us because this is not just
maths this is the application of Venice
right so interact with the real world so
you get lots of words it's real world is
full of words alright how we're going to
work out k we've got another point in
time don't we okay so instead of being
the initial condition 2 equals 0 I
should tell when T equals n the
population is defined they tell us it's
7000 that point okay so let's take that
fit into a bottle and see how it helps
us okay what do I get 7000 eat cause
he's my value for a right and there's my
temp up there yep now I want to make k
the subject okay so what will be the
nice first step / 5000 get 705 yeah now
what okay we can convert this to our law
equation or totally if you want to
figure out that way you can take logs of
both sides okay when you take it on this
side it becomes that when you take it on
this side the e to the power of just
disappears right so you get your 10 okay
alright so now i have k on its own
now it bears actually that a lot of a
lot of questions at this point they'll
ask you actually to give me a decimal
for ki it gets 0.033 something like that
but you don't have to you can leave it
exactly that's quite nice okay is that
right by the way someone check the new
calculator yeah okay now how many use
this thing I've got all my clothes down
right I have my a which is actually just
the initial population I had like a
which tells me how fast this T is
growing the number is quite small right
that corresponds to the fact that really
even though this growth is proportional
to how big it is it's not superfast is
it right ten years and that's all you
grow its we're not used to thinking
about of an exponential growth being
this slow but it really depends really
why don't do that if you draw an
exponential graph right it sort of just
depends on how far you zoom in right if
I zoomed into here for instance okay
it'll look pretty slow but it's still
exhibit in the conditions of being
proportional it's great being
proportional to its site all right I'm
ready to put this in what do i want i
want t to be five years photo which is
15 ok so i'll come to my population
equation which i now have all the pieces
for its 5008 of a que this time's right
so what you got there I'm going to put
this into decimals because it'd be easy
to do 1.5 mod 1.4 okay so you got a
choice at this point you can get your
calculator out you can check that in if
you remember your log laws though you
might notice that um that's the same as
same 5,000 each of the log 1.4 to the
power of 1.5 which is the same as 5,000
that e to the log that should just
cancel each other out so that's actually
one point four to the power of 1.5 which
is somewhat easier to put into your
calculator by the way what do you get
hey 8,000 the 282 now what's the decimal
point 510 K dot I have a question for
you I'll wrestle you population I wait
we're talking people okay now very
interesting what does this mean we're
it's a boy I this means we're at a point
where obviously because we're talking in
we're talking in years right so we're
expecting this not to give us an exact
number right this graph here is
continuous so all the way along here
you've got time this way and population
this way right you've only got that very
limited number of spots that are
actually whole numbers and everything
else you're in between okay so should we
round up cuz it's a point five or should
we bound down down see pre seem pretty
um what's the word unanimous in that
okay now here's the interesting thing
you really can't do both that's a
dangerous thing to say in terms of
population right remember what I said at
the beginning okay what were we doing
what is precious called its modeling
modeling right no one in their right
mind thinks that this is actually giving
you the exact number of up tada at the
end of you know you work out what our
it'll be when the 8280 third baby pops
out okay that's not what we're expecting
okay we know it's an approximation we
know its approximation okay you can
actually say well suppose it was
something like point nine you're like
what am I closer to well I'm closer to
83 and I and it's just an approximation
is tell me roughly how many there are
right a rowdy dad is also fair because
you don't have a whole person yet to you
okay so you can say that
and that is just fine okay nearest birth
years person they're all soon now I
could have started here you can die
kunst are young and said look let's go
it's just using the crazy I want you to
get in your head though why we
introduced the exponential right it's
all about this guy this is the real hero
here okay it just so happens that this
is the solution to that okay but the
idea of exponential graph is all that is
proportionality okay if you understand
that the rest of the topic will fall out